BRIAN GRADY: Stephen Fromkin
is a VR 360 video producer.
He has been at it for a
bit longer than anybody
else that I know.
And I am so happy that you'd
agree to come down-- or up,
I guess.
You came up and [INAUDIBLE]--
came up to do this for us.
So Steve, I am not going
to waste any more time.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Thank you.
BRIAN GRADY: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Brian, and
everyone for having me.
It's been a really fun day.
And I've had a
great time listening
to Neil, Todd, and Jolly.
And I'm going to
add a little bit
that I think will touch upon
probably what each of them
had said and
hopefully expand on it
a little bit for each of you.
I'm going to do so by
starting with a little video.
And hopefully, the
sound that comes out,
pipes through, will
be powerful enough.
So the background
on this is we were
asked to help Visa do
some 360 video for an app
for the Olympics last year.
And this was the product
that-- part of what
this video is, it's
obviously 16 by 9.
But what it's going
to show within it
is some of the behind
the scenes, the results,
and the experiences.
But because it came out of
an app, the final audio,
it's a little tinny.
So hopefully, bear with that,
but it's pretty interesting.
They did a really great job.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Ever fly down a mountain
at 90 miles per hour,
or dance on ice across ice,
or jump through the air
the length of a football field?
For Olympic athletes,
that's everyday training.
But for the rest of us,
there's the Visa 360 Cam.
It's the first mobile app that
brings wearable technology,
mobile capabilities, and
interactive 360 video together
to get fans close to the
athletes the way only Visa can
and reinforce the brand
positioning everywhere
you want to be.
It all started
with the athletes.
We rigged them up with as
many cameras as we could.
Then we turned them loose
to do what they do best.
We took that footage
and stitched together
a panoramic 360-degree sphere.
It works with your
device's gyroscope.
By tilting and moving
your mobile device,
you can control the
camera's perspective.
Look up.
Look down.
Look behind, to the side.
You'll see what the
athlete sees and here what
goes through their mind as they
train for the Winter Games.
By toggling between 360,
face and follow cams,
users get new perspectives
on Olympic training.
-[LAUGHS]
-Even the athletes
were surprised.
They were able to see things
they had never seen before.
And fans reacted in kind.
In just 30 days, over
300,000 downloaded the app.
It was a front-page feature
on the iTunes store.
And then it went global in
over a hundred countries,
from Canada to Japan to Russia,
and places like Google Creative
Sandbox.
[END PLAYBACK]
STEPHEN FROMKIN: OK,
I'm going to stop it
because short on time.
And their app was wonderful.
It did great, all the metrics.
Hooray.
But the point of that
was those athletes
had an experience because
VR, because of 360 video,
that they didn't see coming.
OK, strap this rig to my head.
Great, I'll ski
down the mountain.
And the product was, I had
no idea I was doing that
with my foot, because they were
able to watch, turn around,
and say, oh, never knew that.
And so the power of
VR, as we all know,
is somewhat still growing.
We can imagine it,
but we don't know
exactly what it's going to be.
But this was one of those
scenarios where it happened.
And this was one of those
moments that really reinforces
what we're all doing and
why maybe a lot of us
are interested in this.
So real quick, here's what
I'm going to go through.
I'll give you a real quick
background on me, on what I do,
and give you a little bit of
some of the tech about 360
video production.
And then I'll tell
you a little bit
about what my day-to-day is like
and why maybe I have something
of value to share with you.
You can decide on that.
So my background is in
physical production.
I started traditional
media line producing.
I got quickly into
post-production pipelines
and visual effects.
And I've been doing that for--
[CLEARS THROAT] excuse me.
I've been doing that
for over 15 years.
And then about three years ago,
I worked on a 360 video job.
I had no idea what it was.
And since then, I
did a number of them.
And at the end of
last year, I started
working for a company
called Verse and did
a few projects there.
And then this year in January,
I began working with 360Heros
and now service their
head of production.
So what that means is I'm on
the phone generally four to five
times a day having
a conversation that
goes a little bit like, we
want to do this production.
And we want to do
it with 360 as well.
And that's where
you put the cameras
on the outside of the
room and shoot in, right?
And we say, no, not really.
And then it starts with
the technical conversation.
So how many folks-- just
to create a baseline,
how many folks have shot 360?
We've already--
OK, there's a few.
Good.
So 360Heros makes these.
Our owner and founder invented
this little rig right here.
It was the first one
that went to market
about three years ago.
And it's since sold
over 6,500 through just
an online e-commerce
type store and since then
has made multiple versions.
This is a six-camera rig.
That's a seven-camera rig.
And this is one live-action
solution, live-action data
capture solution, for 360 video.
We also do some other parts
of the technical workflow
because as we
started to shoot, we
started to realize, well,
what about media management?
There are six times as
many files for every take.
There's seven times.
We have a 10-camera
rig, a 12-camera rig,
and a 14-camera rig.
And so obviously, media
management became a thing.
And so we've been playing with
and experimenting and evolving
as we've grown.
But to make sure
everybody understands
a little bit about-- I'm
going to actually skip
this video because we've already
seen something very similar
to this.
And I'm going to skip that
because I think you all
get this.
So I'm going to go straight
to this because this
is what 360 video is like.
It's truly a visual
effects workflow.
It's the theta that we
were looking at earlier.
And some of the other rigs
out there are fantastic.
They do some unbelievable
things on the fly.
Where a jump is
going is outrageous.
It's exciting.
But ultimately, they're
all common in that they're
a compromise.
These two, these are a massive
compromise because I can only
get so much resolution.
I can get a lot.
I can get a little
bit more than some
of the rigs that are out there,
but it's all a compromise.
And the reason is
we are shooting--
and I think it was the picture
of the skyline that we saw.
It was a 2D image,
but it was clearly 3D.
Well, now we're shooting
with cameras that
have separated nodal points.
And so we're creating
parallax issues.
And the only-- everybody
knows what parallax is?
Yeah?
OK.
So if you have an array like
this or anything similar,
you're going to have
to deal with parallax.
You're going to have
to deal with the fact
that when objects in motion--
people, whatever it is--
cross a scene at different
layers, it's still a 2D image.
It doesn't understand Z depth.
It's still a 2D image.
And for that reason,
it becomes somewhat
of a visual effects workflow.
So you can choose how you
want to solve the compromise.
There's that rig there was
done over at Panavision.
And there are a
lot of those rigs.
Those are a bunch of Reds.
And I can only imagine
the fantastic resolution
that would come out of that.
But that's not going to amount
to a hockey player's helmet.
So just like when
you go shoot, you
decide what is it
that's most important.
Is it resolution?
Am I going to shoot a baseball
game or such a wide landscape
that I need that resolution,
I need to use the Red Dragon?
Or can I get away with
something smaller?
And do I need some smaller
because I am mounting it
to a head or a car, or I'm
walking around with it?
And so these are
the conversations
that I-- these are some
of the conversations
that I'm having everyday.
And they start with the
technical challenges
that generally surround the
idea, as I said, with parallax.
With most of these camera rigs,
you're-- and as you may or may
not know, these were made
for, designed for, GoPros--
fantastic, tiny little device
with great resolution and great
frame rate.
So why is frame rate important?
If I shoot at 30, I can
get maximum resolution.
Well, sure.
You could shoot all of these
at 2.7K or 4K and on a six rig,
get a 24K file.
But you're probably not going
to be able to do much with that.
I mean, you can save it for
like 2016, or 2020 even,
when we actually screen those.
But for now, what you want to
do is have a higher frame rate.
Why?
Because with a rig
like this, we're
not talking about genlock.
We're not talking
about cameras that
are in sync with each
other, with a black burst
generator or any other device.
And therefore, they
need to be sunk in post.
They need to be sunk
in your workflow.
So that's, again, one
of the challenges--
or one of the compromises.
You go and you use the Red
rig and tie it all together
with Lockit boxes.
Great.
Brilliant.
So there's lots of
different solutions.
It just depends on
what you're shooting.
So let's talk about that.
And this is really
sort of where I
want to spend most of the time,
which is why I kind of blew
through a lot of that stuff.
So I get into conversations
on a daily basis that
are from either from agencies,
[INAUDIBLE] agencies,
or producers, or just folks who
are really excited about VR.
And they have a project that
they want to talk about.
And they want to figure
out how to do it.
And they want to know if
they should do it themselves,
they should hire us to help
them with production services,
or a they can just do a hybrid.
What should they do?
How should they get this done?
So based on the
folks in the room,
let me share some
of these stories.
And the first one I
want to share-- well,
I'm going to leave it up to you.
What's more
important to you all?
The scenario where-- and
this down here at the bottom,
narrative is where I'm
tempted to talk a little bit
about based on everything
Neil started with and some
of the fantastic notes
from Todd about editorial.
So I'm going to
go with narrative.
We cool with that?
I'm going to start there, OK?
So I get a call.
I get a call, and they say,
we want to shoot a short film.
And it's really just two scenes.
And we want to
shoot an interior,
and there's really just
going to be one guy and then
another character.
And then we want to
shoot an exterior.
And it's like a crime scene.
OK, well, what's
your point of view?
Is it mounted to a person?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Should it be
mounted to a person?
That's what the content creator
needs to kind of understand.
So as a content creator,
you're thinking--
and they don't always
know this right away--
should I mount it and
make it a point of view?
Or is it just a fly on
the wall type of scenario?
Sorry, I'm wandering.
I'm supposed to stay
near this for the video.
Sorry.
So Brian, I told you you can
yell at me when I wander.
BRIAN GRADY: I
don't like to yell.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: I wander.
So the question of camera
position is actually valid.
What makes sense for the shot?
And is it always the same?
In one scene, is it
mounted to a person?
And in another, is it not?
The-- was it Neil who
was showing us the video,
the CGI video, where the police
officer, we're tracking him.
We're following him.
And wham, now we are him.
That's an interesting approach.
But is that what the
content creator wants?
I don't know.
I'm telling you about a call
I literally had the other day
so we don't know yet.
We don't know where
this is going to end.
The next question
is, well, where are
you going to put this media?
Is it going to go
to YouTube 360?
Is it going to go to an app?
Do you want it for Oculus or
Gear, Cardboard, everything?
Because depending on what
you're going to shoot
or where you're
going to distribute,
you want to think about
that when you're shooting.
It's like traditional,
a traditional 16 by 9.
Well, what are my deliverables?
So we're constantly talking
about what those deliverables
might be and how we
can facilitate the best
workflow for that delivery.
The other thing that
comes into play-- and I
jumped ahead on the whole
sort of delivery format thing.
But back to camera position,
what about camera movement?
If it's not mounted to a person,
and it's-- is it in a fixed
point, or is it moving?
Well, a still camera's sort of
maybe boring in a narrative.
You want to sort of drift in
on a dolly shot or a slider.
You're coming in on a jib arm.
Well, you're going
to see all that.
What about the lights?
Narrative, your
lighting-- so all
of these questions about
where do all the gear go?
And where does-- we actually
had one scenario where somebody
said, well, if we
shoot on a stage,
do I have to get rid of craft
services and everything that--
do I have to hide that stuff?
No, you don't have to.
You just-- you're
going to see it.
Well, so can we just
take out the cameras?
Yeah.
Well then, what's behind there?
Well, nothing.
So they were-- but
none of it's wrong.
None of this is wrong.
Take out the camera.
Shoot 180 and comp
something else in.
The idea that you must go out
and shoot with all the cameras
and come back with a perfect
sphere of live-action footage
is kind of a tall order.
And as I said at
the beginning, this
is sort of a visual
effects workflow.
You are capturing pixels.
And after that, you're
manipulating them.
Just by the very nature
of you're putting them
in a stitching
program, and you're
warping them and
distorting them,
and you're materially
changing them,
you might as well just
swallow the bitter pill
that your in an effects
world now and trickery
is part of the recipe.
You have to deal with parallax.
You have to deal with
the fact that there's
going to be multiple
seams getting in the way
and you're going to
have to hide that.
And there's a monopod now you
have to paint out, or a tripod,
or a drone that I can see.
I wanted to see
the beautiful sky.
Now there's a helicopter.
So again, conversations that--
so speaking of narrative, let's
talk about-- where is Neil?
Neil, are you still here?
See, he gave me such
great intro to really what
I think is some of the most
interesting stuff, which
is that indeed,
the language of VR
is not the same as
the language of film.
Screen direction-- everybody
knows what screen direction is?
Somebody enters in the left.
They exit on the right.
If they exit on
the right now, it
looks like they're going
back the other way, right?
That's just one example
of screen direction.
All of these things that we, as
content creators, as directors,
as camera operators--
all of these things
that we have taken as a
foundation for storytelling,
for blocking, for mise en
scene, all of those things
are completely turned
upside down, or inside out.
Or they're all around
us, so to speak, right?
So the questions don't end.
And I'm not going to say
that I have all the answers.
But the discussions are fun.
So let's continue with
that for a second.
Neil's example with "Heat"--
Pacino and De Niro at that
awesome scene in the diner--
master shot coverage-- shot,
reverse, shot, right?
I've actually seen somebody
try to shoot coverage in VR.
And so Jamie and Jolly,
and they're-- sorry,
I'm walking away
from the light again.
Sorry.
So I shoot them,
and I want coverage.
But even in the master shot,
if there's nothing back here,
what's the point?
Form meets function.
So if I need that
type of shot, if I
need that type of storytelling,
maybe I don't need 360.
Maybe I can just tell
this in standard 16 by 9.
But I want 360.
OK, fine.
So now let's build
the shot where
it makes sense for
the camera position
to be a part of
that conversation.
Instead of it being a shot
on De Niro, a shot on Jamie,
a shot on Pacino,
a shot on Jolly,
instead of back and forth
and what we normally
know as editorial
and composition,
we're going to give the
camera a seat at the table.
We're going to put
it at the table.
And just as though
you were a part
of the conversation in
"Heat," for example,
you're going to sit there and
watch so that it's up to you
when there's a dramatic
pause, who are you looking at.
But as a filmmaker, as a content
creator, you have to decide,
is that OK?
Because what if somebody says,
I wonder what's over here now?
[CLINKING]
That's just part of the deal.
So speaking of-- it's like
you did that on purpose.
That was perfect-- sound, right?
So I keep it quiet back there.
Set, be quiet back there.
But when I want
somebody to look,
when I want somebody to jump,
I have that sound go off
and I draw people's attention.
I use peripheral.
Because right now,
my composition-- I'm
looking at this gentleman
right in the front.
What's your name, sir?
SEAN: Sean.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Hi, Sean.
So Sean's sitting there
right at the front, right?
So if I'm focusing on him, I
have sort of a-- let's call
it a composition
I'm focusing on.
Because I'm speaking to him,
so I'm focusing right there.
But if somebody moves over
here, jumps up, starts mayhem,
I have peripheral vision,
would use peripheral vision.
You can do that.
You have a viewable
area in VR, and then you
have the area that you
need you go and look at.
So what I'd like
to do is to stay
on this sort of narrative
idea for a minute
and open the floor up if
there's any specific questions.
If anybody has a
question, whether it's
related to what I'm
saying, what Neil said,
what Todd said about
narrative filmmaking
in VR, or narrative
content creation,
because-- who here is a
director, or a producer,
or controls the
camera, an editor?
Thank you.
OK,
So if you're going
to get into 360,
you are willfully giving up
the two most precious tools--
composition and editorial.
They're evolving.
And how do you embrace that as
opposed to let it restrict you?
What Todd was showing
us with the-- that's
what they're testing.
They're testing how to
embrace the fact that there's
multiple things I can look at.
They're using a certain
amount of points of interest
to discern the
likelihood, and then
provide cuts from shot to shot.
That's exactly what
we're talking about,
is changing the way we think
about editorial or composition.
So any questions
to specific-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So based on
the experiments of VR
that have been done
so far, are there
types of stories that are
particularly well suited
[INAUDIBLE]?
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Types
of fictional stories?
AUDIENCE: Either way.
What seems to be working the
best [INAUDIBLE] storytelling?
STEPHEN FROMKIN: What is working
the best are fictional stories.
Let's start there.
What's most challenging
is narrative,
which is why it's so
fun to talk about,
because we have a
certain language, right?
I know I'm repeating
myself, but because of that,
that's what's most
difficult. We're
used to being
taken on a journey.
And it somewhat
changes when we become
in control of that
journey, whereas we
were just sort of
passive as opposed
to active in that process.
What is working is things
that are experiential,
somewhere where you can give
me the best seat in the house.
If you can give me a seat at--
AUDIENCE: The Super Bowl?
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Super Bowl.
See, I used Super Bowl
as an example earlier
today so I didn't
want to double up,
but it is my favorite example.
50-yard line seats at
the Super, I'm probably
not going to get those.
But I might get a chance
to watch that in VR.
An equally good example, soccer.
Soccer fans?
Rabid soccer fans, anybody?
There's no rabid
soccer fans here?
Brian?
BRIAN GRADY: [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN FROMKIN: OK.
Pick a place where
you know there's
going to be a lot of
energy-- a concert.
A soccer match has a lot of
energy, especially when it's
not in this country.
When it's elsewhere,
it's more fun.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Right.
Those types of
places are where you
can experience not just content,
but the energy because it
becomes immersive.
It becomes infectious.
And it's sort of
what we deal with.
As a viewer, we
see reaction shots.
We see comedy.
We see tears.
We react to those
emotions generally.
So if we feel
connected, it becomes
infectious in the same
way that 16 by 9 would.
That's why Chris Milk keeps
calling VR the great empathy
machine.
To continue answering your
question, what else is working
are music videos because
there's not a lot of rules.
You kind of do
whatever you want.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: It's been
a great talk so far.
My question is
actually about you
said earlier regarding
[INAUDIBLE] shots
don't work because
you lose background.
If I understood that
correctly, you're
talking about the "Heat" scene.
And I'm nos so
familiar with that
as I am with "Pulp Fiction."
But imagine you've got Honey
Bunny and Ringo in the diner.
And then you've got
Vincent Vega and Jules
at the scene at the table.
Why couldn't you shoot
from different views?
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Well,
now you're talking.
So that's a great example.
Thank you.
Did everybody hear that?
AUDIENCE: No.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: So the talky
scene with De Niro and Pacino,
that's just two
guys at a table--
OK, not physically
the most exciting.
Performance-wise,
drama-wise, great.
So you probably want
to be in there tight.
Because if you were directing
that scene, if you're
editing that scene, you're
probably going to say,
yeah, don't pop out
to the wide shot.
Stay in on that tight shot.
I want to be in with those guys
as much as possible, right?
I want to be in with their
eyes, and their emotions,
and their reactions.
But this gentleman--
what's your name, sir?
AUDIENCE: Chris [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Chris.
Thank you, sir.
So what Chris' point was take a
scene from like "Pulp Fiction."
In the diner, you've got Samuel
L. Jackson and John Travolta
and--
AUDIENCE: Uma Thurman.
AUDIENCE: Tim Roth is--
STEPHEN FROMKIN:
It's Tim Roth, right.
And what's her name?
AUDIENCE: Amanda Plummer.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Amanda Plummer?
AUDIENCE: Bunny.
STEPHEN FROMKIN:
Honey Bunny, right.
And so it's a scene where
there's conflict going on.
There's two people
holding everybody--
You've seen "Pulp Fiction."
I'm not going to
ruin this, right?
two people are holding
up the diner, right?
And it's not going well.
Tension is high.
There's a guy there with a gun.
There's a girl
there with the gun.
There's a guy over
here with a gun
coming in from the bathroom.
It's all around you.
And therein lies
where this is fun.
Because you could potentially,
if it was blocked properly
and if it evolved
properly, instead
of having a shot where
everything's taking place here
and there's no
reason to look here,
you kind of open it
up-- maybe not to 360,
but maybe to at least
give it such a wide view
that you feel the
tension because you
have to look around to see where
the conflict is coming from.
There's people yelling.
There's people screaming.
There's people with guns.
So it's a good example.
I would rather be a part
of that scene in VR--
or I don't know
if I would rather.
I wouldn't mind seeing De
Niro and Pacino up close.
I mean, come on.
But that is a great example
of narrative storytelling
that would benefit from
just some sort of trial,
just somebody experimenting.
And that's what-- yes?
Copy that.
Sorry.
So go ahead, sir.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just a
thought on that.
Great question.
But I feel like the different
point of view at the same time
would involve consistent
VR, and it would not
be highly quantitative.
But it's a really tough thing.
But if you can pull that
off, that would be amazing.
That would be the way to go.
And if you use [INAUDIBLE]
or anything else,
the coordination
would be amazing.
But let me know.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I've got kind
of two questions that
are into this equation.
And if I may, I'm
going to step up
there so that it
can be recorded.
STEPHEN FROMKIN: Yeah, sure.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
One of them is the
relationship between 3D
that is immersive audio.
MALE SPEAKER: Speak
into the mic as well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this one.
Essentially, we live in a
period where, at most, it's
kicking in.
We have object-oriented
sound location.
That means it's going to look
beyond the number of speakers
that are in your space
for an exhibition.
And that means that you can
have an absolute position
of a particular
element and sound that
can drive the narrative, that
can drive where you should
be directing your attention.
So we have the potential
here that audio
could lead the way for the
narrative to be directed.
And currently, we have
light-field technology
where there isn't a single
focal point in any direction,
but rather, a series
of focal points
that you can drive as a viewer.
Do we yet have a
sense that we'll
be able to not only track the
eye's movement within what
you're viewing this immersive
space in, but also that depth
of focus within that field?
STEPHEN FROMKIN: OK.
So I'm going to take
them as two separate.
First, let's talk about audio.
It's a great question because
audio is a perfect example
of how to help tell the story.
And it doesn't matter if
it's narrative or not.
Our experience in life
is to respond to sounds,
respond to motion, right?
So we see something move.
We look.
That draws our attention.
We hear something.
Using a either
binaural audio rig
or some other multichannel-type
positional microphone
based wherever the rig is,
wherever your 360 cam rig is,
and then post-producing
it in a way that
draws the viewer left,
right, back, up is complex,
but it's workable.
It's doable.
There are people who
are using binural audio,
recording it,
faking it, taking--
AUDIENCE: Still composites.
STEPHEN FROMKIN:
--taking stems and then
adding it so the binaural audio,
and it basically matched up
with the accelerometer,
just like the video is,
and it can look wherever.
I'm not as-- let's take
light-field technology
and just put that
aside for a second,
and just say that as
the tools, whether it
be light-field technology, or
just getting Z data captured
and being able to adjust
focus, or literally
push in from the position even
though the camera never moved--
some of those types of
things are absolutely
going to add-- what
basically we're talking about
is, how much more
can we virtually,
digitally, or otherwise
fake the moves of the camera
and therefore build the
story pretty much as we want?
And that's all coming.
It's just as the
technology evolves.
I got the red light, like
they give the red light when
the comedian's almost over.
I have a lot of
other-- obviously,
I have numerous anecdotes that
I could share about production.
I'm happy to share them.
I wish there was time
to share more with you
or talk to each of you.
I'll certainly hang
out for a little bit
and answer more questions.
I do have-- my last slide is
something that was requested.
If you're going to
start production,
if you're going to go out
there and start doing this,
and you want to do
so, I highly suggest
the 7 rig and some of the
other items that are there.
This is all actually
on our website.
You can buy a lot
of the stuff there.
But we're not the only game.
And we're not the only solution.
We're just a good one.
And we've been doing
this for a while,
and we're very open
source about it.
There are a lot of production
companies out there,
and we're just happy
that you're trying it
and that you're invited
us to share some
of our info and experience.
So thank you again, Brian.
BRIAN GRADY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]